Almost 5 million people saw the headline
48 hours ago that OpenAI have a secret
large language model that got gold at
the International Math Olympiad. Here
though are nine ways to misread that
headline. First, this means the AI is
now as good as the best mathematicians
and could put them out of a job. The IMO
is extremely difficult but contains
human expert written questions, not
questions that no one knows the answer
to yet. I am in awe of the high school
competitors who get any medal in it or
even qualify to be in the competition
truly. But as one UCL math professor
said yesterday, math research is about
solving problems no one yet knows how to
solve. And this requires significant
creativity. something notably absent
from OpenAI's IMO solutions. Now,
OpenAI's model, apparently out around
the end of the year, did not find a
correct proof for the hardest problem,
requiring the most creativity. That's
unlike, by the way, a fair few of the
young human participants. The model did
get problem 1 through five correct. That
is bloody impressive and enough for a
gold. Second misreading of the headline
though. This means that OpenAI are now
in the lead in AI or maybe language
models for mathematics. Well, we
actually don't know what the Google
effort got in the IMO. This professor is
hearing that Google DeepMind also got
gold but has not yet announced it. We
will find out in the coming week
apparently whether Google DeepMind got
problem six correct. Was this why OpenAI
rushed the announcement to get there
before Google and steal the headlines?
Now one of the Google DeepMind
researchers on AI for mathematics and a
lead of their famous well is actually
famous well famous to me alpha geometry
system that I discussed 18 months ago
True TR retweeted this tweet.
Apparently, AI organizations were asked
not to report their results for a week
to give some space for human
celebration. Unfortunately, Nome Brown
of OpenAI said that this message somehow
didn't get through to OpenAI. Maybe it
wasn't relayed to them. We don't know,
but this explains why we don't yet have
the Google DeepMind results, which I
believe are coming out on the 28th of
July, and some other results from a
company called Harmonic. Third way to
misread this gold medal headline that
none of this is relevant to whether AI
will reduce entry-level white collar
jobs. I frankly disagree. I think it is
relevant. One of the leads on OpenAI's
new secretive model, Jerry Chuarek, if
I'm pronouncing that right, revealed
that it is not specialized for
mathematics and draws on the same
research technique used to power most of
OpenAI's other offerings. This is bigger
news than it sounds because it means
that this secret model did not use tools
or specialized fine-tuning to optimize
for the mathematics use case. Even one
of OpenAI's chief critics at a rival lab
and an IMO gold medalist himself
conceded that for this result to be
achieved by a pure language model was
impressive. To the degree he said that
this was indicative of general reasoning
training without specialization, that's
significant. But many of you will still
be saying, "Nah, none of this is
relevant." But let me try to put the
strongest case yet. Remember, this
reinforcement learning system within
OpenAI was the same one responsible for
that generalpurpose computer using agent
whose headlines you may have seen
recently. I'll play the clip now because
it's soon going to be rolled out to All
Plus users. But it's that system that
can browse the web and perform deep
research for you. Millions of people saw
the headlines about OpenAI's agent mode
that can spin up its own virtual
computer, operate the mouse, navigate
the browser visually. Now, yes, that
agent is a bit jank, but this same
researcher revealed that the agent mode
system is an earlier version of the same
one that performs so exceptionally at
the IMO. The thing is that more limited
agent mode drawing on an older base
model is approaching human baselines in
a range of realworld domains. This is
what I mean then when I say that this
headline is not irrelevant to the impact
on white collar jobs. The agent mode
released just a few days ago and just to
stress again in the same family as the
IMO goldinning agent was tested on
realworld professional work such as
preparing a competitive analysis of
ondemand urgent care providers and
identifying viable water wells for a new
green hydrogen facility. Pay attention
to the bars in blue because that's the
win rate of chachi agent versus humans.
As you can see, for a variety of tasks,
it's approaching a 50% win rate. You
don't need me to make the obvious point
that if this is CHPT agent, what about
this model we're getting at the end of
the year? Suddenly, models exceeding
most human participants in the IMO
competition doesn't seem so irrelevant.
Then there is data science tasks in
which OpenAI claim to actually have a
superior system to most human
performers. The emphasis there should be
on most performers because again
remember these questions were designed
by human experts. Therefore there must
be some humans by definition who can ace
these questions comfortably. Now what is
more white collar unfortunately than
filling out spreadsheets or editing them
in the case of spreadsheet bench? In
this case, as you can see here, human
performance on average is still far
superior to CHBT agent. But it is barely
speculative at this point to summize
that the model we're getting at the end
of the year might score say 75% or 80%
on spreadsheet bench. The obvious point
to be made is that surely expert
spreadsheet will just increase their
productivity by using these tools. And
that's true, but it does beg the
question about what the incentives will
be at that point to hire entry-level
helpers. If entry-level human white
collar workers can no longer complement
the systems, then that could really
start showing up in the data. How about
the headlines meaning that we are
actually close then to fully eliminating
white collar jobs? The logic would go,
if it can get gold in the IMO, then
isn't it just better than us at
everything? This leads us to the fourth
way that many might misread the
headline, which is that if we're getting
gold in the International Math Olympiad,
we are actually really quite close to
eliminating white collar jobs. Well, if
you have read the 42page system card for
these latest systems like chatt agents,
and frankly, who hasn't read that
42-page system card, then you'll see
that the hallucination rate of these new
agents drawing on the same techniques
again as the math wiz went up. To repeat
that same single reinforcement learning
system in the words of the open AAI
researcher produced higher
hallucinations within chatbt agent on
simple QA which is one benchmark
measuring hallucinations you can see a
drop of around 4% compared to the 03
system with browsing. Likewise, on
another measure of hallucinations,
person QA, it should be noted that
OpenAI added the caveat that it was
actually Wikipedia getting stuff wrong
often. So, there may be some noise in
that data. That would be the same data
used to train the models, but that's
another discussion. On evaluations
designed to test whether ChatBT agent
refuses to do highstakes financial tasks
such as making financial account
transfers, the agent mode was worse than
the previous 40 or 03 operator. In other
words, it would be more liable to try to
do something highly risky. And that's
not the only highstake setting in which
things can go haywire under the new
system. OpenAI were testing chatbt agent
essentially on whether it could produce
a bioweapon or at least whether it had
one skill pertaining to that ability.
Now chatbt agent was unable to install
or run the biodesign tool. But that's no
biggie. But here's where it gets worse.
The chatbt agent researched and wrote
substitute scripts. Then it
misrepresented those scripts outputs as
real tool results. Any terrorist using
it for this purpose then is going to get
mightily pissed off. But seriously, this
is all critical context for these new
breakthrough results that you hear, for
example, the IMO gold. In my opinion,
even if the best of a language model's
answers are better than before, if you
can't employ a language model at its
lowest point when it hallucinates, then
you might not employ it at its best. So,
while I foresee there being significant
impact on entry-level jobs, it's a far
cry from eliminating white collar jobs.
That prediction, by the way, is also
echoed by that math professor who said
he sees an increasing number of
mathematicians improving their
productivity by using language models to
search for known parts of a tentative
proof. Another massive positive, of
course, is that younger entrance to a
field can use these kind of tools to
more rapidly ascend to expertise level.
Before we leave, human jobs for just a
moment, a word about real jobs you can
apply for today. The sponsors of this
video are 80,000 hours. And while I have
mentioned their podcast and YouTube
channel before, just a quick reminder
that they have a job board link in the
description with hundreds of jobs
filtered for positive impact. Just going
to refresh the page because what I
didn't mention last time when talking
about this is that these jobs are around
the world as well. notice for example
Paris. If you are interested in any of
this, obviously it would be amazing if
you could use the link in the
description. Fifth way not to misread
the OpenAI headline. You might have
looked at that headline on Twitter and
said, "No, it's all hype and AI models
have actually hit a plateau." Well, try
telling that to this machine learning
researcher who got almost half a million
impressions for being disappointed in
how the latest models like Gro 4 did on
the International Math Olympiad. They
found that Gemini 2.5 Pro did the best
of the models they tested, but Gro 4
performed particularly poorly. I could
point to my own benchmark, Simple Bench,
as some form of proof that Grock 4
wasn't purely benchmark hacking and that
there is plenty of genuine progress in
AI. After all, I made this benchmark to
expose the gap between human performance
and model performance. And yet, that gap
is shrinking rapidly. There probably
will be a Simple Bench V2 one day soon.
And yes, we are working on benchmarking
models like Kimmy. Trust me, we are
working on it. Anyway, even that
researcher, Ravid Schwarz, did have to
admit by saying, "Well played, Gnome."
Nome Brown of OpenAI, well played. If
even after that concession, you still
think that all AI progress is just hype.
Wait till the end of the video.
Obligatory mention by the way, for me at
least, that I did call that AI would get
gold in the IMO this year. I can't find
the quote. I think it was from a few
months ago. Maybe one of you can find
the quote. Sixth, potential misreading.
Some of the more trusting among you may
misread the headline as being about a
peer-reviewed research paper in which we
can learn all about the methodology.
After all, this is crucial research and
part of OpenAI's main push towards
general intelligence or AGI. Nope, quite
the opposite. We have gone from
peer-reviewed papers from the Frontier
Labs, say circa 2022, to website posts
up to 2024, to now 3:00 a.m. Twitter
threads. That leaves us with an
unbelievable amount of unknowns about
this IMO achievement. The smartest man
in the world by IQ, Terrence Tao, said
that there are all sorts of unknowns in
how the result was achieved. each one of
which would cast a result in a slightly
more favorable or less favorable light.
Mikey question along with him is did the
model submit multiple attempts for
example that is by the way allowed for
the human participants. Neil Nandanda
again asks about more subtle hacks but
we just don't know. This forces us
including me to have to read between the
lines of obscure esoteric tweets. But I
would say that one key technique does
seem to be just to let inference run for
longer. As in train models to output yet
longer chains of thought. Again,
according to Gnome Brown, this model
thinks for a long time, for hours. And
he says there's a lot of room to push
that test time compute and efficiency
further. How much compute was used
during the competition? We don't know.
How much cash would such inference cost
an average user? Again, we don't know.
But it does seem to hint that we really
will be getting those $2,000 a month
pricing tiers for chatbt. The most
intriguing hint for me and some of you
watching will be the fact that these new
techniques, he says, make LLMs a lot
better at hard to verify tasks. If
OpenAI do take the lead in software
engineering, for example, by the end of
the year, that really would be a big
shakeup. Unlike competitive coding,
software engineering is harder to
verify, but has huge economic impact.
But back to that sixth misreading, while
I strongly suspect Google's announcement
will be more quantitative on the 28th
and detailed, it will likely still fall
far short of complete transparency. Such
is the money at stake in AI these days.
Speaking of which, by the way, side
note, would you turn down a $300 million
annual salary to work at Meta? Make that
312, by the way, in case you weren't
convinced. Seventh misreading, that we
will have to wait to the end of the year
to get a glimpse of OpenAI's progress.
No, it seems GPT5 reasoning alpha is
coming pretty soon. Not the same as the
model coming out at the end of the year
that got gold, but nevertheless, it will
give us a taste of the latest progress
at OpenAI. Eighth, misreading that the
AI news these days is nothing but insane
progress and exponentials. Actually, no.
See this new meter report. I have
chatted with the lead author both in
person and online and will hopefully do
a deep dive soon. But the TLDDR is that
against expectations, even the
participants expectations, language
models can slow down developers in
certain settings, especially on more
complex code bases averaging over a
million lines of code in which the
developers already have lots of
experience. Recent language models at
least just get a little bit overwhelmed.
We'll see about the new generation of
models, but this does remind us that if
competition coding were the same as real
world software engineering, you just
wouldn't see results like this. The
developers thought that using language
models within cursor would speed them up
by say 25%, but it actually slowed them
down by around 20%. Again, it's a small
study, but a fascinating one that I'll
come back to. Ninth and finally, try not
to misread the gold medal headline and
think that, you know, generative AI is
just all about phony benchmarks. It
doesn't ever have any real world impact.
Well, aside from a potential negative
impact of our new age of intelligent
surveillance that's covered in my most
recent documentary on Patreon. Do check
it out. AI and language models can also
have and have had positive impact in
hard numbers, realworld settings. Just
take Alpha Revolve, and I did do a
separate video on this, but it made data
centers about 0.7% more efficient in the
real world. or more technically, the
Alpha Reevolve system continuously
recovers on average 0.7% of Google's
worldwide compute resources. This
sustained efficiency gain means that at
any given moment, more tasks can be
completed on the same computational
footprint. That's an example of the
marrying of language models, essentially
next word predictors, with symbolic
pre-programmed systems. That seems to be
the sweet spot at the moment for real
world impact. And I suspect on the 28th
of July, Google's submission to the
International Math Olympiad will use a
bit of both. We'll see. Did they get
problem six correct? Did they
demonstrate real creativity? Time will
tell. Either way, I would argue, as you
can see, plenty of ways of misreading
the headline. But what do you think in a
meta way? Have I misread the headline?
Quite possible. even if I have. Thank
you so much for watching to the end and
have a wonderful